hi slugs right now it is time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition it's
just one scoop of water every day that's
it no need for a million different pills
and supplements to look out for your
health to make it easy athletic greens
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com
tuesday again that's athleticgreens.com
tuesday to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance we love you
athletic rings with dipsy your sanctuary
is waiting escape into a world where
pleasure is your only priority
for listeners of our show dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsy stories.com tuesday
that's 30 days of full access for free
when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a stories.com
tuesday you can see me on the road i've
been having the best time it's like
i know i say this every time but it's
really unbelievable it's my favorite
thing to do is meet you guys to perform
for you total honor i love it you guys
are i think i have the best audience in
the world i really do believe that
you can see me i'm gonna be in austin
texas at the vulcan theater
on the i think july 29th
i will also be in
springfield missouri in the blue room
comedy club august
20
19th and 20th i'll be in pittsburgh in
september tempe in september
caluso california september 30th at a
casino it's going to be so fun one night
only
then i have a bunch of dates in a bunch
of other places go to andyletterman.com
shows i am probably coming to you
[Music]
so esther i just wanted to ask so that
picture you posted with the was the
chanel was fake
oh yes oh
cause the louis is real
but can i flex my fake chanel for a
second yes no it is i found it in my
childhood bedroom i bought it in high
school oh it's perfect in 2005 it's a
very y2k i decided to dress like marc
maron today
wait but also my bag this is a coach bag
from high school
i mean i think it's cute what you're
doing but i think you're not like
hitting the challenge what do you mean
what challenge the challenge is how much
money can we spend
oh [ __ ]
the challenge is we have a very rich
born from a wealthy family
carl co-producer whatever the hell we
call him so okay can you explain what
happened carlos got carlos got a chain
okay carlos got a louis vuitton chain
it's the only time i've ever replied to
his story by the way that's because of
the change sad she hates you well can i
she's supposed to be she doesn't hate me
i have facebook she's trying to cover up
the hate
a dm is truth
i and i want to know if you guys think
i've been doing the right thing or the
wrong thing for months
carlos has been telling me he wants a
chain and i've been like
i don't know like i don't think so and
he finally got it
and everyone's happy everyone really
happy look it's a great i want to screw
up rarely do i ever say like oh my god i
need to get the gold one i want to get
the gold one i i okay i went in to get
the gold one so i have a rule with louis
vuitton because i am now okay i am now
trying to trust
that i am going to have money i don't
want to live with the story that money
is going to run out
and i want to like
i don't want to be someone that [ __ ]
and is scared i want to trust that it's
happening i love this
so
when carlos sent the picture
of him when he tagged us in a story
where he said did you say challenge no i
didn't say i took it as a challenge yeah
he was buying the chain he tagged us in
it i i wrote challenge accepted i
immediately went to the louis vuitton
store when i walk into a louis vuitton
store i have one rule you're leaving
buying something hell yeah you're not
window shopping window shopping is old
poor people thought
not to calling you guys poor
you can rise up if i can do it i live in
my car through if i can do it you can do
it seriously agreed i did it off of
jokes you guys can figure out your thing
saw you living in your car with a makeup
bag that was a grocery plastic bag i
know we already established that she
still carries that around i got this
that's what it has the tag
[Laughter]
and my mouth guard is loosely floating
in there with a bunch of makeup i'm
really into the cufflinks the will you i
like the colored one but i really this
is the one you want but it's in gold
it's men's
but in gold
and it's it's really so i went in for
that and they didn't have it and then i
was like i got to just buy oh wait wait
wait
what is that how much is that five nine
five ninety oh it's a bracelet i want
that as a necklace but it's like the
balenciaga well you're little
less carbs you can do it
you're about a week away [ __ ] honestly
you're a week away my newborn would fit
around her neck
should i get this ring esther come get
my will you test if my new room will fit
around her neck
oh that felt good
you're like wet hair she actually bathed
i'll say this i didn't dislike it
did was it like a soft pillow
it was nice did my fu papa hang over you
isn't that so cute this is great oh
i do love it on the model too carlos are
you okay with me matching your necklace
completely i cannot tell you why you
have to
i'm asian so when we match with with a
person it means we're in a committed
relationship okay so twinning is not
just twinning twinning means like if
we're that's our way of showing pda
because we're not going to make out in
public but we're going to be it's going
to be known we're together i guess this
is actually pretty unacceptable we've
literally been here trying to get you to
match us on everything i did
you did one thing one thing she got a
touch of your name you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you guys yeah you ended up hold on
i would prefer if we we just kind of try
to brush the tattoo under the rug well
the tattoo is not it's not a fake tattoo
it was actually a real tattoo i know i'm
starting to think that is a very real
tattoo so there's everyone well they
want other ones are fading except that
one um i from a financial standpoint i'm
gonna say that the salines were a bigger
commitment than the tattoo what do you
think i'll price-wise by the way i have
no qualms about the tattoo i'm happy
with the tattoo if i never see you i've
never seen someone lie anymore
her nose is growing okay pinocchio i
never need to see her again i will
always be happy that i have this don't
do this she's such not a drug addict
she's like
look this is the kalila side wait i get
great druggy veins
oh you guys i have the juice
i literally when i saw that right yes
when um phlebotomists see me it's
the person who takes your blood that's
their name is phlebotomy that's yeah
i've never heard of that there's blood
in there the etymology of it is blood
yeah flow and blood
blotting yeah you guys can i flex that
i'm having a y2k moment because
no she's not touching where are they
from
oh i'm getting out i'm getting the ones
that are like are they on forever no i'm
getting the like beads where they're
like they're you put them on if you want
to lose weight you get them tight okay
so they like they [ __ ] with you while
you eat wait can i get one that says
kalila if it's on forever
wait a second that's like when um
like culturally some women out of uh
myanmar they have their rings around
their neck and they add a ring for each
lover i would be like phase of their
life so like
it's like it's going down there guys uh
the longer your neck is the more
regarded you are like in society is how
i believe it but if you commit a crime
they take that thing off so then you no
longer have the neck support so you're
kind of you have you're like the bent
neck lady
so that's like esther is that what
happened to you is that why your neck is
i got mine taken off does it actually
make your neck longer to wear i mean it
looks like their necks are far longer
than they
normally be but i think it's so
beautiful and i think we should start
with that with the best
i want that before i go on a plane so
when i i just
you're right guys i wear my mask can i
just tell you i will never not wear my
mask on the plane i am a gape open mouth
like i when i the second i'm on a plane
my head hits the window yes it's a
window seat don't you [ __ ] with me with
an aisle there's no middles oh my god
we'd be so perfect together i like the
aisle you're not for clients
i wouldn't even speak to you on a plane
wait andy can you show um visually how
it looks i can describe i can it looks
like i can show you visually what i look
like it looks like my parents have to
make a very tough decision about whether
to unplug me or not
like is the brain is the heart still
there is the consciousness like i'm like
it's so open like when i wake up my mask
is wet
it's wet
it's wide it looks like you know when
guys with beards haven't they're all
stretched down like it's like this open
i'm like it's a full like
beetlejuice in the waiting room like
stretched out this is i'm i'm getting
pick me vibes you're just laying there
open mouth
i cover it by insert here but i have one
hole
i'm like you my problem is not pick me
we are skull [ __ ] so yeah
you're just sitting here bragging
i would answer the quiz no sandwich
guys i found a sex that he sent me yeah
what did it say okay yeah
because by the way i didn't get my
people to cut up the clip and not to be
i know it all but it did go viral i just
did ask people for that clip and it was
the most popular clip i've ever posted a
reminder guys we're talking about the
guy who annie made out with on a plane
that we found out on the show has
perished yeah and he's here
it sounds like he fingered me and then
turned into dust
it has it happens a lot i'm like medusa
but my [ __ ] i'm a puss
oh now i just want a papoosa oh i love
that
do you put that down i don't like to
wear low advice jeans that early it's a
little rough do you eat it with the um
the cortido what's that it's like the
kind of it's like a they're called she
doesn't need any of it carlos doesn't
let her carlos smacks it out of her hand
that's not true i have pupusas the
cortino's right next to it go back to
pictures
you have to eat it with that it's like a
slaw
oh i never had that it really is so
[ __ ] good what is it
it's like oh no it's salvadorian el
salvador it's so fluffy benji's
housekeeper used to make them for us
i mean it's
if you wanted people to be
more upset with you that was the line
you're like sometimes i'm on a diet and
sometimes i have a ethnic woman handing
me food it's not my housekeeper i'm just
the house guest um that's friend
privilege that's rich guy friend
privilege i'm all about it i i have the
same neck problem as you on the plane
but my other problem on the plane is i
don't like my feet on the ground i
cannot sleep with my or nap with my feet
because you're meant to be giving birth
let's be honest well i think it's
because like i feel light-headed and
like my blood pressure drops i always
have to have like my knees to my chest
but this is what i felt like covering
your vagina because you were raped by
every doctor so i do this or i'm leaning
like this but i'm like bouncing oh yeah
oh i get smacked but i fall are you good
at falling asleep because i will fall
asleep i can fall asleep just about
anywhere yeah oh guys also i want to
mark this day as the day that annie
letterman learned about
tock contouring
filters do you see my button nose
it looks
really good
if you look up close it's pretty bad how
did you do that they have the like the
they have a filter where you put it on
you follow the lines and it's of a very
petite beautiful asian woman so i'm just
i have an asian woman's contoured nose i
have a question about that though
because a lot of times they're trying to
make the nose skinnier right how do i
make the nose less of a bird beak
because mine is very narrow this way up
front take a knuckle sandwich for once
[ __ ] just flatten it i'm gonna punch
you the
i'm gonna punch you to the moon
i'm gonna punch you to the moon you're
gonna come back so cute
so i'm not trying to decrease the width
i'm trying to decrease the the length at
which it protrudes does that make sense
well you have to elongate the chin
oh
i'm going to give you some filler okay
dr annie's here oh no yeah i'm going to
give you some okay do we have a we don't
have a red pointer do we
seems like something like a laser a
laser pointer does that not seem like
something we have we definitely have one
right
yes pete pete gets it
yeah you can tell me everything that's
wrong in my face i want to do the
lorenzo llamas what's that he had a show
i can't remember what the [ __ ] it was
called i brought it up on this before
yeah it was like hot or not or something
and they would have girls come and
they'd like circle what they needed to
change about themselves
what
that was
it's been the renegade's fault this
whole time laser pointer okay let's play
this game
so dr andy's here
okay
i blind her okay here we go yeah close
your eyes
okay i would first of all have to keep
my eyes open because i have asymmetry in
my eyes one is oh thank you for
mentioning i've been disgusted by you
the whole time [ __ ] lazy here we go
okay first of all
thin the lips out i would take the lips
are just they're over line they're over
lying their juice don't say what's
happening with my lips don't project
okay sorry okay so the juicy lips are
actually
they're offsetting the tiny little
button nose
the tiny little button nose doctor i'm
not sure we're going to make the gap
bigger because i like the gap i want to
stick my tongue oh yeah
gap wideners i want to widen the gap
that's the thing so i saw some girl
doing it on tiktok
why didn't the gap sound like we're just
taking a pay cut we're like we want to
widen the gap okay we want guys to make
more money than us
okay so we wanted to match your thigh
gap only one now you have a thought you
have to i'm the only one with the
[ __ ] i will never starting a fire
with my [ __ ] quarters okay okay what
else wait but can i know for real though
i would bring out the forehead you want
to make this you want to
shave down the honker yeah we go no no
here this one this one cut the nose off
let's remove the nose okay we'll add
filler here that pulls it out
we add filler down to the tip here yeah
okay
okay
so it's a straight line okay
then we we pull the forehead out about
my jawline the jawline perfect we like
the drawing very masculine
it matches the shoulders i have a
serious question and then no more tits
would we all do
someone was like you got to stop telling
kalila that she's pretty all right she's
an ugly [ __ ] and we're listening thanks
guys better show now right you're ugly
would you guys do the gap filler thing
or the thing that it's a device that you
put on your teeth that literally widens
the gap oh do they have that yes yeah i
want it on you but these are too close
would we do it you talk with it right
here even her teeth are kind of annie
look at that smushing together
that's how wide they get that seems a
little too wide i think that's like you
can't keep liquid in your mouth wide
i think the goal is to get a strawberry
stuck oh she's getting them smaller no
that this is the order which she's
widening her gap i'm happy people are
like
jesus it looks like it would hurt but
would you guys do it or not for real no
um
i
[Music]
yeah my my mom would kill me she spent
so much of her money
so guys i can't do it she's so pretty
look at her she's so pretty
as there's pretty two people are like
why are you something because it's funny
to be mean to esther did you guys
understand
it's the funny she likes it she's
pretending she doesn't right now yeah
but she's also low-key the hottest one i
know but it's funny you get you get to
be
uh no but esther like yeah no esther's
fun because then it's like they go oh
it's a secret we figured out that
esther's hot
it's like i've known this [ __ ] for a
while okay yeah she can get us
you've been hot the moment i laid eyes
on you thank you i appreciate your time
but she has to play this game or her hot
girl
investigations don't work
do you know what i mean
thank you that it's a game i'm yeah
you're right i'm just
pretending to be ugly no again guys i
haven't could just go back to the
meanspiration episode where we figured
out that esther is just kind of
constantly just
doing a webinar just tip-topping you
know i you're you know our resident
inspector and investigative journalist i
would actually take you know what i
would actually take the labia yeah from
here yeah i'd place it on the labial
folds of your nose
i think that's genius
i would just put yeah a [ __ ] on your
cheeks i would put one here replace my
nose your nose will look smaller if the
the puffy [ __ ] lips are here
like you're a baseball player
so i
this is a bit of a long um story so um
sit tight dare you to get through it
without me interrupting
sit tight i'm gonna try this is what i
this is what i need from you guys i need
you to tell me what to do okay because i
am very conflicted in the moment so um
do this
let's all get this
what do you call it the ponytail snatch
yeah ponytail facelifts oh like sewn in
it only lasts like two weeks you're like
was this worth it
is that when it starts drooping one goes
first uh-oh okay back on track back on
track good attempt danny
okay here we go so um about a month and
a half ago um my sister's car got broken
into and all of our dive gear got stolen
and if you guys don't know dive gear can
be very expensive for instance one pair
of fins um one of her paraffins is a
meanders fins each one is eight hundred
dollars so you guys buy louis vuitton we
buy expensive dive gear right i don't
buy louis vuitton just to be clear uh by
the way yes you do it's like enough is
enough join the club my designer purse
was so under 400. the rear windshield
was smashed into these things got taken
but we're like well how many people
really are going around with me andro's
fins right so my friends then went on
craigslist and today they found
the perpetrators reselling the exact so
two fins were stolen they're a pink and
a blue pair one was jewelry this one's
one of them so gender neutral of them
and so they they took a picture here's a
mistake they made they didn't sell them
separately they took a picture of all of
our stuff bunched up together so i can
see that it's all of my all of our stuff
and they're reselling it on craigslist
right
but
instead of just calling cops because we
filed a police report then we have the
police report number i went ahead we
went ahead and got the phone number
connected to the craigslist account and
we found these people online
was it his team was it thick boy studios
close
and so
and so what happened was when i saw the
photograph of the woman and her husband
they looked like a very
happy
couple with five children
and now i don't know if i should pursue
it let's call them right now
do you have their phone number
i do because we've been in contact like
hey i'm interested in buying like i'm
interested i i went ahead and was going
to repurchase it call the police and
show up and grab the stuff but then now
i'm like
yeah maybe you don't have to get the
police involved but maybe you go like
this is your last shot but that's what i
wanted to do mike you can't be breaking
into people's cars like yeah like you're
now your sister like they don't know
what financially your sister can afford
what if they can i ask you this are you
a hundred percent sure that those are
yours a hundred percent they have a
picture of my lobster gauge which is
only all of my stuff was purchased from
one specific dive shop and where this
where my dive stuff was stolen none of
this stuff is sold speaking of lobster
gauges can you spread your legs i want
to see what i would do down here
okay oh my god there's a hole
[Music]
you guys our next partner has a product
i use literally every day it's so good
i know annie takes it too no i started
taking athletic greens i learned about
it
i know from you guys but what i love
about it is it's all right there in one
simple step i i mix it in with some
juice i know you guys do it with water
but
and then i have all the nutrients you
just have to be a baby that i need
in a day and i don't have to be
stressing about oh i'm eating a
cheeseburger today no i already got the
veggies i'm going to make a bra of
athletic greens so you can suckle it out
to be a bigger baby
75 high quality vitamins minerals whole
food sourced superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens yes i sort of said that
correct to help keep you
and okay start your day right start is a
hard word for me and this special blend
of ingredients supports your gut health
your nervous system your immune system
your energy recovery focus and aging all
of the things that are important plus
it's keto it's paleo
it's vegan dairy-free or gluten-free and
it only contains less than one gram of
sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals we hate
the nasty chemicals it does taste good
though too or anything artificial and
yeah it really does taste good it's a
very mild tasting flavor i use i just i
drink it with just cold water and it is
perfect in fact i kind of crave the
flavor yeah it does make it just feels
good it's like it feels like a healthy
little it feels like a life hack like oh
my god i can just get all this in one
easy one fell swoop it's the first thing
i do in the morning
it just eliminates all you know
stressing out about oh did i eat this
right did i eat for like the rest of the
day i love taking my little packets on
the road too it keeps me just like
having a normalcy while i'm just running
around everywhere you guys right now it
is time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it there's no
need for millions pills and supplements
to look out for your health to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
tuesday again that is athleticgreens.com
tuesday to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
[Music]
yeah i've been robbed before and it's
such a horrible feeling you just feel
helpless vulnerable like i hate that
feeling so much and when someone
um
broke basically what happened well i can
get into that later but i think that
let's get into it okay
so my old apartment that um
basically i had an apartment that i
shared with my friend who you all know
um
who is also my nanny and when i moved
out i left a lot of my stuff there and
she she took over for me so it was like
our apartment still she's still there
and she was airbnb
and when she did someone broke through
like the locked door and stole a bunch
of our stuff and a lot of my stuff got
stolen and
i just felt so violated it was like
stuff from high school i was never
getting it back but then some of it did
get recovered by the police and getting
it back was i just felt so good about it
and
i know that's not really exactly
relevant but i do think that as someone
who knows what it feels like to be
robbed like i think you should do
whatever you can to like get justice i
have a question did the cops feel robbed
when they spend a whole day finding
britney spears posters for you
were there
are you kidding me this was our [ __ ]
day [ __ ] is there not a cat in a tree i
can say that's when that's the taxpayer
a part of me just wants to
offer it up to the cycle of life would
be of tragedies and celebrations good
things bad things that's how when it
happened my sister and jewels were
obviously very like upset because i had
gifted in those most of those things
which are you know i
jules can't afford that like on her own
and she late loves to dive so i was just
going to be like look guys it's just
objects very replaceable things you know
let's not cry about it
so my instinct when i saw the picture of
the husband and wife and i'm like five
children i went like sleuthing like i
went all i got all of their information
i'm like i just don't know if i wanna
like
you know what i mean like theft oh
here's another piece of information i
want you to have they didn't steal
wallet money or anything else they just
stole the dive stuff so there is some
integrity in the theft no it's easier to
sell that and you could get busted
stealing someone's yeah stuff versus the
credit is there a world where you could
give them a chance like this isn't an
ebay drop-off store like this is like
they
could you ask hey just curious where did
you guys get these
well that's already you're they're never
going to reply to you here's the thing i
think you just you just go
and then you go with like
you know no i don't know
showing up is scary because then you
don't know who has a gun and who's like
they're are they gonna shoot them
so you gotta bring your spare gun bring
your stuff
come in full dive gear okay
it's like i'm assuming it's bulletproof
yeah no almost just a chest yeah just
come in like a bulletproof like
like swat team thing but with fins okay
so they know your craft
and then
be like this is my stuff grab it i think
it's like because
i do understand like this sort of like
forgiveness aspect where you're like
okay you're like this is your hustle and
you're trying to take care of your
family you don't want to get them like
arrested or your family like separated
but you need your [ __ ] back and you need
like to have a moment where like this is
my ship but couldn't i do that without
having people involved like how is there
a way where i can how do you get your
stuff back just like hey can i like
pretend that i'm buying it right and
then i go there and i'm like look guys
that was the plan yeah um no cops
involved just being like look like i
really don't want to like out you just
robin i just love this stuff i want to
give you guys like you know offer you
grace can i just take my stuff back but
then you're just expecting that someone
who robbed you is gonna be like a good
person yeah and that's really probably
not the case and they'll just keep doing
it it's like you can't i've been trying
to work on this too with my ego where
it's like i i have this like desire to
like teach people lessons it's just like
not my business to teach them lessons
but it's my boundary it's like if you
steal my [ __ ] i want it back
like and i and i
like give it back to me there's also so
many scammers out there i can't tell you
how many times i've been driving around
in la the most recent one was such an
obvious scam they threw something at my
car while i was driving to make it sound
like i hit them
so they told me to pull over i was so
scared because i'm always like i'm sure
i did it wrong wrong right but then i
put it together i'm like i never touched
their car and of course when i pull over
they're like we're driving our sick
grandma for her cancer treatments they
had this whole you're like wrong girl i
don't even talk to my grandmother
that [ __ ] won't give me my jewelry no i
was and this was like a couple years ago
like and i was just like i'm sorry like
i'm a babysitter i'll give you i gave
them like fifty dollars cash you are a
babysitter i know i was like and i and
it always happened to me too when i was
driving to my 01 camry i feel like they
saw me as this victim that they could
take advantage of it always happened and
like
why why do i have to [ __ ] deal with
that i know it's well maybe they just
thought there was no one in the car
they're like this car is driving itself
we got to throw something to stop it
it's a ghost that's um bobby does
something similar but he's afraid of
paperwork so he'll never call like 9-1-1
even if someone's like dying in front of
him he'll never assist he'll never be a
good samaritan like to someone dying
because he's just like paperwork can't
do paperwork i can't stay for paperwork
so we dropped off one of our foster dogs
two weeks ago and coming out of the
parking lot he barely tapped into
another car that was parked and it was
in a neighborhood and he um initially um
was like well that was barely anything
right but then the dude came out and he
was like hey like you know nice man he
was like did you like hit my car
and
he just wanted to get out of it he's
like this means paperwork insurance
companies i don't want to deal with it
he five hundred dollars he was like here
you go and the guy's like he's like
stuck into so much stuff it's like
there's here you're gonna have to peel
it out of this taco bell but it's here
right it's but you know it's called
crumples here and the car by the way was
like a really beat up like i had so many
dings and scratches on it but he was
like just take it i don't want to deal
with the paperwork and the guy was so
[ __ ] happy and i was like why'd you
do that like there's insurance for a
reason he but then he has a point it's
like
i have it
i you know i don't want to deal with it
let's just go you can do that you can do
that but i also look at it like this
like
what you don't know
it's a dangerous thing to steal from
people it's not like just like a chill
like oh this was an opportunity like
they stole from six cars
how do you know that they're not gonna
do that and there's gonna be like a
shootout at some point or they're not
going to like do that to someone who has
nothing that's all they had you know
or they have a family like just because
you guys don't have kids doesn't mean
that like you couldn't have been a
family going that had this right and my
sister said the same thing because i was
like well what about if they're hard up
she was like there are a lot of people
who are hard up and yeah there's a
million things and don't do that so five
kids like it's not like abortions are
illegal yet you know but i tried to do
the math in my head and all five kids
are grown so i think it's actually not
the couple in the picture that are the
perpetrators but one of their kids who
are using the mom's like you know family
of course of course right
yeah it's just it's like
yeah it's it's breaking into people's
houses like it's honestly like it's
unsafe it's like if they're willing to
break the law there where else are they
willing to break the law like you don't
know it's just like they're like wow we
just need some formula for our kids it's
like so does [ __ ] all of our [ __ ]
rich everybody needs formula for their
kids like do you know what i mean it's
like you gotta like
and i understand that there's like you
know but is the charity letting someone
rob you i don't know yeah maybe there's
maybe to feel better there's another
form of charity you can like support
like just to offset how you feel about
taking that away when thieves anonymous
yeah
maybe yeah i don't know
but i i know you mean it's hard when
people are struggling like that's that's
hard but also
being robbed [ __ ] sucks i've had when
dave's car has been broken into it's so
it's so violated it's so violating my
car was broken into
um
not that long ago and it was like so
yeah you just feel like [ __ ] like they
just took like and it wasn't even that
much stuff but then it's weird
when they break in and they leave
certain things i'm like that's
like why is there only one shoe what did
you do that's what i'm saying like they
left all of what i thought was like you
know like money and credit card and
everything so in my head i was like
there is some integrity here i disagree
i feel like they saw the valuable
equipment broke it took that as quick as
they could and didn't dig around and
also you found them for a reason like
you know it's like the universe brought
them to you it's like justice shall be
served right and it's not even just me
who um found him it was the dive
community because i
here's what i love about it it's like i
was i was about to buy
the of the whole new set over again and
instead of the dive shop owner saying
you know what or probably making an
extra 2k that day on stuff that i was
going to purchase she was like
no like let me try and find them on
and she helped me
and she found them
wow so i think you're right i think that
the universe even though i was offering
it up to the universe as like a loss i
think that that moment um of her saying
no let me find let me find it for you
was the universe saying hey you need it
back yeah also so like focus on like
what's yours you know like it's not like
always about like
saving other people that's a great
instinct to have but it's like when are
you like kind of selling yourself out
where it's like that's your stuff and
it's not like yes you can buy more and
that's like you know that's not the
point the point is like you broke into
my space you you broke my property and
then you stole my property and then
you're trying to resell it it's like in
all of that time you could have like
gotten a job at a surface shop and not
to mention
being able to buy all those rear
windshield completely smashed yeah so
that's a big car and six other cars not
just a cost like the [ __ ]
inconvenience of having to get that
fixed my dad always says because
whenever i drive his car he's like
you're going to crash i'm like i'll pay
for it he's like you're not i'm going to
be sitting in the repair shop he gets
really mad anyway have you ever had a
joke stolen because it's the same
feeling i've had that once too whereas
literally a celebrity
watched my late night set told me this
is starting to become unbelievable
i know you're friends with celebs but
they're not watching yourself wrote me
an email saying how much they loved it
two weeks later used one of my jokes as
their instagram caption i was like
it was i felt so [ __ ] violated i've
had it i've had someone someone just did
something on netflix
on one of the netflix's of joke things
and i got like dms and people like she
stole your thing and it's like here's
what i choose
i choose to think that people are not
stealing my jokes even though it's
absolutely word for word i just choose
i mean even though like you have the
evidence and stuff i choose the same
thing as you i don't care i think well i
just have to be like because
it's easy to go this person's like it's
like it just doesn't matter it's like no
it's just i just go like and there's
some like i had a thing where someone
posted something that was the exact same
thing i didn't it was after i'd done it
and i just
i just hit her up and was like i'm
already this is already out there it's
not a good look for you
i'm not mad at you just
take it down oh you told her to take it
down take it down you can't have the
same it's the exact same thing
ultimately yeah like i knows maybe i
said a hacky thing i look at myself as
i'm like i'm a renewable resource i
don't care steal my [ __ ] go ahead but at
that moment the first time it happened
you're just like
you have so much power i have nothing
i'm helpless like
you told me you [ __ ] liked it it's
always people that are like less
successful than me that do it so i'm
like
have it i'm better at this than you i'm
so much better i could write that in my
sleep but also the joke that from the
netflix thing was a joke that i kind of
didn't like doing anymore like i i was
just kind of felt like
it felt like
i just been doing it for a while i'd
already done it on like canadian tv when
i was in montreal like i'd already like
used it and when i use it on my set it
feels like a cheap moment for me
and
i remember seeing her do it and going
like you're doing that here like this is
like a real clo like why are you like
like just like i would not be
comfortable doing that in front of some
of the people but
you know and then i just figured like
i'm like i have more than her who cares
like and i'm not it doesn't matter it's
like they've both been recorded in
different places like i could make a
whole to do about it or i can just i
didn't want it like it's almost like i
manifested it i didn't want to do the
joke anymore i i haven't no i'm not
going to ever do it again i have a
question for you guys so this happened
to bobby so um let's suppose you had um
somebody send you um an open mic or
let's say from sacramento an open micro
um someone's like hey i have this video
of this open mic or doing your entire 15
minute set at the store
um
but you know that this person is
probably never going to make it but they
are going in the open mic circuit and
doing the exact word-for-word
embarrassing for them i had i because
that's what happened to bobby and it was
a friend of mine who was like wait have
i and sent me the whole set uh you know
what i would do i would literally say to
the person so your friend was an open
mic or no just saw the thing saw the
thing but but weird because it was
actually a co-worker doing like a
bringer room in sacramento and he was he
went because he that was like someone
that he knew but he had seen bobby show
like three times before and he was like
this sounds really familiar and he so he
sent the video and i was like that's
word for word so when he confronted the
friend he was like yeah dude i just draw
inspiration from like you know comic
idols that i like i'm like yeah but
that's verbatim
yeah and also you can't like
you can't meme you can't make a meme
into a joke like you can't make a thing
that already exists into a joke like it
has
your comedy is to come from your head
i'm sorry like it just has to be yours
like you can't if you hear someone's
premise and you go like oh i have a
better way to word it that's stealing a
joke you're stealing it's like
and i just i'm not in other people's
heads and i'm not
i would so much rather just not falsely
accuse someone of something that i'm
just like
it's good it's like if this happened
this is what's supposed to happen and
i'm just gonna like drop the joke or
i've already posted it you're it's a bad
look for you i already have this done i
had a girl back in the day
i had this joke about like dogs being
colorblind or whatever and she
did it verbatim in front of me and i'd
done it in montreal i'd done it on
company central like i had already done
it like it was an embarrassing amount of
times i had done it
and she was like she did it and someone
told me and i just went like hey like
don't do my joke and she's like oh i
didn't and i go you did and it's not
your fault like it's fine you've
definitely seen me do it a million times
and just stop doing it she goes i
thought it was cheap anyway and i was
like bye and then years later when amy
schumer got in trouble for stealing
jokes when that was like in the news she
wanted to she was like being interviewed
for an article and she hit me up and
she's like hey can we do about that time
that like we had the same joke i go you
stole the joke from me amy schumer that
amy schumer was in the in the news okay
yeah so this girl hit me up yeah and she
goes hey they want to do an article i
think we should do like a and this is
like you're trying to attach yourself to
my name right now i'm a successful
comedian and i just wrote it back i went
you stole the joke
whether you meant to or not i'm not like
mad at you
you stole the joke
i'd done it several times in front of
your [ __ ] face i guess i was a little
mad
uh no but it was just like and she goes
um
and then i said and then you said it's
cheap you can have it no [ __ ] it was a
great joke it was so good that you stole
it from him
and whether you did it consciously or
subconsciously you did
and that's it and she goes oh i i'm
sorry i didn't really go good day and
then good day
i've seen her we're fine
such a a guy who hits on you and you
reject him and then suddenly he wants to
tell you how ugly you are yeah that's
what she did yeah yeah it's so
disgusting and that's why like i know i
was saying that earlier with the other
girl where i was like it but the joke
felt the the jokes were out
i'd outgrown the jokes that the girl did
on netflix so i'm like
but
also i had a friend who
this girl that told me she didn't want
to do comedy and then she ended up
like
she was like oh i do want to do comedy
and then she started telling me her
jokes that she was doing overweight and
they were jokes that i had just been
doing for
a full year
in front of her and i was like those are
and she was oh no sometimes like people
pick up each other like you've never
written a joke and all of your jokes are
my jokes and you've been at every show
i've done
oh and i'm like it's some people are
crazy and they think that they can like
be so weird like you know when you're
getting lied to and you're it's just the
two of you and you're like
is there a hidden camera here because
uh we both know the information so you
know what i mean pathological liars i
think and she was very rich i think she
was just so used to just like she can
get whatever she wants but i had to stop
being i went not only can i not be
friends with you
like
for me because you're literally the
least safe person i've ever met
it would be bad for you to be friends
with me you're going and doing i am a
professional comedian i'm well known
like you know i wasn't like huge or
anything but i was like well no like
those jokes are like my jokes like those
are annie letterman jokes so you look
like a [ __ ] idiot and also get out of
my house like i was just like
you psycho to say it to my own face get
out of my house and try to gaslight me
about my own [ __ ] jokes what did
bobby do when that happened i'm assuming
nothing i think i got more worked up
than him because i was like well i have
a direct line to who this person is
because it was my a co-worker of my
friends who went to the bringer you know
show so i was really embarrassed and
when they said the thing about the
homage and everything that was to you
you had said something or they said yeah
i had said something i was like hey dude
like he can't do that
and bobby was just like he's never gonna
make it anyway so like who cares you
know but i'm like but bobby was more
operating on the mindset of like
you know like let him have his moment
like he's
but i'm like no i'd need to
i need to just on your behalf because i
was embarrassed
well
why is it that you could but why is it
that you can do that and be upset that
way yeah but someone's allowed to steal
your property
she's more protective over bobby baby um
i think it's because if i if now if
there was information that i had dug up
about that open micros family
like he has five kids looked at a
picture when it humanized when someone
is human to me versus just a thought it
really strikes me different it hits me
different where i'm like [ __ ] they're
really just like everyone's just trying
their best yeah but to this whole thing
you know
you're right you're right parents and
you're right siblings and you know i
think
you know whether it's a warm cup of
coffee baking in a warm sunlight or
listening to a sexy story pleasure is
all around us okay with different well
not all of us yeah no that's true
carlos is miserable with dipsy your
sanctuary is waiting escape into a world
where pleasure is your only priority
i'm a very auditory person so i love
dipsy because it i'm able to
um how do i say this fantasize about my
high school crush or the boy next door
or what are some other ones that you
what are some other stories that you're
like your work co-host or i mean your
co-worker
it's your job
the mic stand at the comedy club the
random job um
but guys dipsy is an app full of
hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women it is a
really fun time you can be all
horned up no no no and they bring
scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and characters no matter who
you're into or what turns you on find
stories about that intriguing co-worker
with a british accent
[Laughter]
hooking up with your hot yoga instructor
that'll be for you annie since i don't
go to yoga class
i took you once
oh yeah it was zoom she shot the
computer quite fast yeah that's true
but um dipsy also has sleep stories
wellness sessions and they also now
offer written stories and we all really
love dipsy we've been texting about like
the different stories we've been
listening to honestly it's a good time
also they have sleep stories and
wellness stories as well by the way and
now they also offer written stories
well those are that's really hard for me
to uh sell guys don't worry we still
have all the audio options you take the
reading for listeners of our show dipsy
is offering an extended 30-day free
trial when you go to
dipsystories.comtuesday that's 30 days
of full access for free when you go to
d-i-p-s-e-a stories.com
tuesday
dipsy stories dot com slash tuesday it's
free honestly you might as well sign up
and just see
what the deal is
[Music]
you're right it's like richard kuklinski
was a great dad but did he tie cats
together and you know like torture
animals and kill people in cold blood
yeah richard kuklinski the god i think
it's richard banana break oh my god he
got horny from the [ __ ] water talk
he's like i better stand up before my
banana shows
[Music]
[Applause]
i i hate to lose [ __ ] see finally i'm
letting you be straight i hate to
speculate on your dick size yet again
but your body really indicates that you
have a massive dong
wait someone told me that back in the
day when you were doing open mics
you used to take like boner pills oh
yeah with yeah at the comedy store yeah
is that true yeah with like yeah it was
just getting boned up
i feel like i remember you guys talking
about that but you really took them yeah
because some guys thought it was funny
they're called hot rod from the gas
station no they're from uh no again
they're not from the gas station some
guys so you said some guys it's always
funny i just didn't want two different
guys you've got a boner so you got
together with guys and you guys took
boner pills
what did they do you get an erection for
like uh like 40 hours and then they'd
blow you or like
after
no we wouldn't get blown what would you
don't act like it's [ __ ] not weird
that you were getting boners with each
other
i thought it was funny at the time and
now looking back it's weird did i guys
did i tell you a story about how i had a
friend
on the show survivor and how she was she
went really really far on the show
and but i didn't watch her season so she
was like kyle i want to go to the
philippines with you so i was like this
[ __ ] has been on survivor like she's
going to be no problem to travel with
and um that was a mistake because i
didn't watch her season when i came back
from the philippines i watched her
season and i said i should have known
she was the villain of the [ __ ] show
yeah what was her name again
i can't say oh yeah obviously yeah i'm
um internet friends with one of the most
epic survivor villains she's a big fan
of the show
of this year yeah oh my gosh she's
amazing it would be so fun to do
if they did like i know they have done
it but like a version for people like us
like survivor
you know like like a survivor type or
big brother but it's like comedian not
coming but like our us the three of us
and maybe carlos and pete
bobby and i have talked about this and i
just think that poppy's busy
bobby's playing video games he's not
answering us
he's all of a sudden gonna text us back
when we're like hey do you want to go on
a extreme camping that's exactly if it's
if the cameras are on and you tell them
it's for tv a thousand percent but it
has to be like abc right it has to be
like a good number yeah good money but
we can't be getting him he didn't go on
freeform did he did he ever go on your
show he did yeah oh he was on the show
yeah yeah that's so weird everyone
even jenna
i was watching this live on some lady on
tik tok and she pointed out a red flag
in a man that i had never really
considered before and let me read it to
you i was like wait longer
to me before
she said red flag a guy who actually
chokes you as hard as you want the first
time you ask
whoa
okay i have a choke red flag
that's very different from that explain
my choking red flag is i hooked up with
this guy
who was a little chokey right and he was
really like the appeal of him is he was
okay so he was at a party with my
friends i thought he was like kind of an
idiot but he was six eight
and i mean he was just so massive and
but he was like kind of annoying
and then at the end of the night we were
leaving
and um
i said something where i was like i just
made some comment where was like yeah i
haven't had like a rough one in a while
or something and he clotheslined me onto
the hood of a car
and i was like what does that mean like
he just like
he just like pushes you clothesline is
not fun like i said no no it was fun oh
you like me in clothesline it was okay
the moment okay okay here you
go okay i'll be the car i'll be that way
yeah do a fake version okay so like i'm
the car and the guy he just like went
like that pushed me under the car but he
was in the front like he just went like
i went i really like i was like i just
haven't had like a rough
sexual experience and he just like
smacked me down he smacked her
it was so hard
it was just what i want it was just like
what i had asked for and i was like oh
this is not this was like an old time
this is not how i am now
but um i was just in for you know color
me molested but i like it rough that
used to be my line
um but you had just met that i said that
and he yeah he was a friend of my friend
they were like trying to set me up with
but i just found him to be like he was
very annoying and he was so tall i was
like you couldn't like ignore how
annoying he was because there was so
much annoying
and so i said my line that's what it was
i said calling me molested but i like it
rough and he just
i'm like without a beat just like and it
wasn't didn't hurt me but he just like
pushed he just like pushed me a little
bit and it was good and then so i went
home with him and we had like four days
of like a crazy thing
but he was like
he would check in too much like it was
too sweet so like he would be kind of
like and he'd go
like hey like he'd be like i just let
unsettlers gonna say i love you like it
was like so close like and i understand
i was like probably allowing him to do
things that weren't normal
i was a weird it was a fluke what do you
mean
you it would still be okay we don't give
a [ __ ] she [ __ ] i know but it's just
like i [ __ ] my brother i like being
pregnant yeah you're right
all my snow smashed in that's how she
got the gap it's actually chipped
um
from [ __ ]
but um i got my heel up on my [ __ ]
let's go okay start running let me try
that i'm joking it's a joke
here i go i got it too go ahead
so um there was like he would like spit
in my mouth
and like
he just was so
bit and his he had a huge dick
it was uncircumcised which i am
respectful i enjoy yeah i've enjoyed the
same it does give you bacterial
vaginosis about 99 of the time so wash
the shmag out of your [ __ ]
pee hoods okay if you can just [ __ ]
take a little q-tip you don't have to
put in the hole just you know remove the
turtleneck because i smell i was
smelling up the joint for a while a
couple weeks after that um
but anyway so
i love you
um so but he was like falling in love oh
and i was like you're not gonna if you
spit in my mouth i'm not gonna meet your
parents do you know what i mean like
really really why not it was a separate
you have to understand i did not like
this okay okay you just
but i used to have that where i was very
disassociated with like i would
disassociate
um
like sex sex from actual any sort of
love or affection of my own like
insecurities or whatever and the reason
i had such rough sex i think is because
it it got me out of my like
fight or flight like i was it made me
not feel raped to be
fake raped kind of
and um
what is that like because you feel like
you're choosing to do this so like it's
mine now i think so and also it was
almost like it was almost role-play-ish
what we were doing so it was like i
wasn't like myself it's a fantasy yeah
so i just wasn't feeling like i wasn't
in myself being myself
and which is like sad to think of but
you know it's still a struggle i mean i
got
i got diddled
but um
um we're working on hypnosis
but i also think this is very relatable
yeah but anyway
so he would like check in so much which
is like you do want someone to be nice
you don't want but it was like breaking
too much character so i'd be like hey
and i i just want to be like the only
time i want you to say hey is when
you've gone a little too far and i'm
purple and you're pounding my chest like
come on dude because right you two like
it was too either or and then i brought
it okay mistake is you guys didn't have
a safe word he came to a show we didn't
have a seat you're right and so you know
and hey was not my side forward it was
like
what is going on so you're saying a guy
who doesn't choke you enough is also a
red flag
it was just like what are we doing here
like commit or not or not but i
there have been time i will say this i
like a guy my my biggest turn on is when
a guy knows his strength so all of the
physical things that he does is very
measured in his head i know that she can
take this amount of blunt force
you know to the face i know that and it
it's that's the perfect guy for me
either and you know it's usually guys
who are trained in mma
it's usually guys who know that who have
done this over and over in practice who
know exactly what a punch feels like how
much force is behind it i've just never
heard this
blood trauma
not associated with a murder no she's
like
am i the only one
the staircase
like yes i've just never heard it
sexually but i'm i'm open so that's what
i like because i've had guys not know
their own strength and i me ask it i
mean we're getting into a little rough
play and they go a little too hard or
they don't know how to pull hair
properly but i'm just like i don't i
don't like that you didn't do it a light
pull is so annoying like is that your
elbow on there like what are you doing
wait also when you pull hair don't pull
in the front of my head also don't pull
from the tips pull from the scalp the
scalp because you're a [ __ ] caveman i
love that we all know how to pull hair
yes i know it's making me horny um
but also wait what was that we're all
just pros at it i do want to have a hair
pulling contest at some point and see
who does it i have pulled your hair and
it got weird
like turn the cameras off
it got weird
wipe off the camera lens real quick
um
yeah i feel like we should just force
our we should have forced sex between
the three of us and see who and see if
we can have a podcast right after we
should all just commit to having sex i
would do that obviously
and we just had a clothesline
listen you know we could do and then
sell
page put it on patreon for half a
million the discussion afterwards yeah
you guys we forced ourselves to have sex
and then now we're gonna talk about it
throw an episode up there we raped
ourselves with our co-hosts
one person wasn't raped
i'm like ill lesbians gross okay i guess
i'll do it for the show if it's for work
that's like a account get as high as you
want i'll get as drunk as i can
it's just todd's got to give me the pass
it's work it's like todd you want this
lifestyle or not it's a tax write-off
you want this lifestyle you want to go
back and live in the car with me
todd i gotta eat some [ __ ] all right
this is behind the wall okay you
threatening todd with the car you want
to live in the car with me yeah we're
not breaking up you're coming with me
you're gonna live in the car i just
wanna know if we would break somewhere
in between at all because i can go in i
can dissociate from who i am kalila
right i'm going to be talking the whole
time but you're going to know exactly
who's i'm going to be laughing i'm going
to be telling you no way no way i cannot
show up as myself i'm going to be
someone different and i can get through
the whole thing seamlessly are you
talking about the whole thing esther's
bush i can totally get through it i
think i wanna bring [ __ ] cheers
literally esther i i promise you i can
but if i come in as me and you guys
start calling me by my name i can't do
it i'm bringing in this i i will do it
but i'm i have the strap on
i want to know [ __ ] i'm the guy we can
take turns i'm the alpha i don't want
the strap-on so this works for me and
finally we've settled it
i'm esther can blow me and you can you
can do the other end oh my god you have
to suck her [ __ ]
fake
what is the purple i that to me i'm like
we want to see her moves nobody's
getting anything here but what if we
secretly fall in love and there's a love
triangle that's what people speculate
i've seen some comments
okay what about let's say for instance
i'm now in love with you
maybe i mean listen i think you guys
kind of love me look what
i feel like everyone in this room just
really wants to know but in love like
annie like what if i really catch
feelings for you but then you catch
feelings for esther but esther no when
you guys play hard to get and don't
respond to my texts i'm like they're so
into me
please no response well
oh keep playing wait i'm that's amazing
i'm going to copy that no you
already do it there's nothing
oh you're going to copy one of people
yeah no ever were we talking about the
last episode if a guy can't get hard was
that you with you i don't know or i was
on something where someone's like when i
got i'm like i just go like i'm just too
hot
oh no we did talk about that in the last
episode you guys can reframe everything
to just be like
i mean you don't have to operate in the
world that way you don't go to court
with it but yeah it's for your own the
inside court the inner court but like we
have our own egos if i can't get a guy
there it is a hit to my ego so i don't
want to be around it when they can't
when he can't like get it back up or if
he goes like flaccid you know halfway in
between because i always think i'm gonna
take it on as my shame so i just have to
leave
like hey it's okay i know it's like can
we just end it you figure it out we'll
get back together later this is why like
a sexual history report is really
valuable it's like how many women have i
would love for someone to find a sexual
history report on me i blacked out so
many years i would love the scribe
to reveal themselves
i have no clue for a guy because it's
like if they've been with tons and tons
of people and this is not going to be
that special for them like forget it i'm
not
i'm not wasting this i have a question
i was talking to a handsome male comic
last night he's like
not well known but he's like a good
looking guy
these guys like really
do i'm starting to have like a lot of
compassion for that type of guy because
they really do just see the lens from
their own like the world from their own
lens and they do just assume girls are
like them because i can't remember what
i was talking about maybe i was talking
about like
um wanting to go see when i saw green
daisy i wanted to meet billy jones he's
like oh he wouldn't have todd have been
jealous and i was like todd was with me
what do you think i was going to blow
him
like i they just assume if you admire
someone you want to suck their dick
i never and this is what i want to ask
you guys because i know there are girls
that are like that they're chuckle
[ __ ] they're um
the roadies on the road like there's no
shame in that like i love chuckle
[ __ ] and stuff i just for me
i always saw very clearly
that if you like [ __ ] someone that it
could
that's
up here and everyone's trying to [ __ ]
that it would devalue you yeah i always
wanted to like
there to be like a mutual admiration you
know like i never really like it's not
like when i was doing nothing but when i
started comedy like if i were to go into
like green day's green room i would be
like did you see my set like are you
gonna come to my show you know well i
was on the same festival as them like i
was trying to get back to be like we're
like that but i view them as peers not i
would want to be viewed as a period i
would never i just never and maybe it's
because of the stuff that happened with
my teacher but i never saw like a game
you know when people are like i had this
guy that worked at a really big network
back in the day who like invited me to
the so house to talk about a project and
i naively
was like oh but he started just touching
my knee a bunch and i just started i
went uh oh
like this is the thing
he was married so i kept going like oh
let me see pictures of your kids like i
just kept being like that damn
acknowledging his marriage right without
like swatting him because this was like
he was gonna give me like
almost like a sitcom really and he's
like the thing i love about you is how
promiscuous we are and you are and it
was so weird because my set was about at
that time this was like 2012. i like it
you could actually cry
this is making me so angry but you can
see my set online like it was from like
i did a showcase in 2012 that was like
what my set was back then it was all
about if you see any jokes i'm doing now
i've fixed them and made them better um
i haven't been in a special yet um
i my jokes were about how i had just
quit drinking and how sex was like
disgusting to me and i used to like do
it when i was drunk and how it was so
weird i used to be like a [ __ ] because i
just didn't relate to that at all so it
was just so weird that they just he
didn't hear my set like he didn't see
what my son was about i was like but i
wasn't i'm not like talking about being
promiscuous i'm talking about like
having a drinking problem and how i'm
not like that now
and so that was a good lesson too i was
like i think some people just hear key
words you know
they're not really and they also see you
and they don't even hear they're like i
wanna like i was like i always have that
kind of like a bigger i don't know i
always thought i had like an under but
it wasn't and that's good to know when
i'm like delivering my jokes it's like
make sure they i can only i only have so
much control over how things land but i
you know it's good to be conscious of
that so then what were you saying i i
think that girls who uh you know chuckle
[ __ ] say for instance or people who
you know shoot for the moon and want to
sleep with what's his name the guy
khloe kardashian's dude tristan thompson
say for instance right
um
they're
i
i think they understand that the dynamic
is gonna be that dynamic right and that
it's probably there is something to be
gained but there's also a lot you're
never really gonna which is
all to say which is what i feared when i
met bobby
all the reason why i when the first
um we went on a date that afternoon and
he said hey come to the comedy store
tonight i was like no thank you because
i knew that that was his place of power
that there would be a big power dynamic
between us that i would feel
like he would feel like a king in his
home and i was just well just as someone
that saw you at the comedy store i was
like who's bobby lee i was like what is
this
i was like oh my but i think i met you
already like three four years into my
relationship with him right so it was
months before i ever stepped foot there
and the first time that i did
go into anything with him was at a
benefit a show for like little at the
laugh factory and i was like in and out
of there but it's because i fear that i
i fear that big power dynamic how did
you even know
i would have never like um
it's just living in l.a long enough yeah
you know it's like who am i you know the
mutual admiration thing i'm like this no
he's not going to come overnight
we got molested by
people in power yes i just have always
been conscious of that that it's like
they take they don't give you anything
right
i think you're right when the first time
that happened to me i was 16 and i went
on a date with a manager
of i'll say the bands like the dead
kennedys and like and when he was 30
years old and he was banned school not
him yeah he managed a lot of like big
bands and there was a show at the house
of blues that he invited me to he got me
backstage i drank a lot of vodka i
remember being on like watching the show
um at the house of blues and he was an
important person there
clearly he knew everybody there
and i remember
him grinding up behind me and then i
turned i my hand i don't know what it
was or like he took my hand and it
rubbed up against a belly button ring
and i was like this guy is a [ __ ]
creep not to say that the belly button
is what made him a creep but i knew that
it was on he was trying to get my hands
down his pants on the dance floor
and so what i did was
he had driven me there i'm 16. i don't
have money i'm all the way in hollywood
i don't have money to
know that like
people might not want to just be your
friend like you don't know that yet
you're like oh maybe they just thought i
was great you're like too young to
process yeah you're too young it was
really and so what i did he he did this
i like i froze and i'm like oh i think i
gotta go he's like well i'm not gonna
drive you and so he was like here's
fifty dollars
i don't know if it was 50. fully 50 but
i remember having to get off
the outside off the cab at exact when it
hit 50 and then walk the next like two
miles home why do you gotta bring people
into it put your arm down
uh because i only had 50 bucks and i
remember feeling so shameful and feeling
like oh my god like who do i think i am
like at some point i believe that this
was fun or like it was an impo you know
and i think you're right you learn early
yeah can i say my mom has a story
exactly like that where she went
somewhere with a guy when she was super
young and realized right away it was
scary had no and she had to walk home in
the middle of the night like it's like
the same story where these guys just
like like dump you off because you're
not giving them what they want is that
why you walk every day yeah
i've also never in my 13 years in this
business i thought you could say on this
earth like finally she admits it she's
13.
i've never i'm just realizing i've never
had someone in this business
like be like you want something in
exchange for
never mind i'm just
you guys must be hotter than me it's
settled
you're just short like there's no one
delivering them
here's why annie and i have slept faced
we
and when you have this stuff happen
there is like i don't know how to not be
sexual like i really like i try like to
just be like normal but it's a part of
like
it just became who i am a little bit you
know yeah i sucked a lot of dick i
didn't sleep with a lot of people but i
was a baby [ __ ] in other ways i could
not stop making out yeah i didn't [ __ ]
how many people until i started getting
blacked out
i'm like you all raped me i will say i
feel like now that i'm in my 30s i'm
like really feeling more confident about
maybe dressing sexier like posting sexy
things because i'm like
to be honest like i'm not in my 20s not
everyone wants to [ __ ] me like i'm just
i'm like almost like owning
that you know what i'm a little older
and i'm gonna have fun like yeah i don't
know if that makes sense but when you're
20 like like celebrating scary men want
to rape you all the time i think and
then when you're in the 30s they like
they don't care they're focused on the
youngins no it's just really much
scarier men want to rape you
that is very sinister if at 37 a guy
really wants to like when you're in your
70s there's some very scary men though
very
scary
they're not just taking your fins
they're breaking in though
but um
yeah it uh
that guy i went to the um
i went to the so house with him the
executive
and he like took there was like a
billiards when he took me in and he just
like i wasn't looking and he wrapped his
arm around my waist and he pulled me in
and he went
you look so your ass looks so hot in
those pants and i was like
let and i just went i literally went
i pulled put an x up and i went no no no
i went i'm good i'm good at comedy like
i'm good like i believe in myself like i
was like i'm talented you said that yes
i was like i'm good i worked so hard i
worked so hard
i was like i'm good and he went oh i'm
so embarrassed
and i was like
i was like look man like i just thought
you were married like i didn't think
this was like a thing you know and he
was like oh i'm so embarrassed i'm in
this bad marriage and we're like going
down the elevator at this point yeah
like it's over right
and i'm like he had just told me he
wanted to have like a louis a version of
louis that's with me right
you know and it's like i'm like uh what
a weird yes praying on your dreams right
and then so
we like get down he's like hey like just
hopefully like you know just to keep you
know for my own like embarrassment if
you can just keep this between us and he
goes but i'll see you in montreal what
happens in montreal stays in montreal i
was like i'm still gonna not
i went i'm still good
and then um i called him the next day i
called his office the next day and i was
like so when are we moving forward with
the thing and i ended up
doing like
they ended up paying me for this web
series but it just didn't work out for
other reasons but they were going to go
through with it because i just was like
i'm going to follow up i had another
show i used to work on where the
executive or where the main producer who
i was like friends with you know i would
go we'd all go hang out at his house and
stuff i had been dating someone
and then the minute that we broke up and
i was like going as a single person
he kept trying to make out with me and
it was like shoot your shot once like
that's fine like i i you know i'm funny
i'm fun like i i'm it's flattering yes
thank you for like being attracted to me
and stuff but like i like this job and i
don't and i don't like you like that and
i've never thought of you like that you
know so he leans in and i was like no no
like i'm not and he was like and then he
was like embarrassed then i'm there like
trying to make him not feel embarrassed
right like it's cool man just like yeah
it's just a no he tried again and i was
like
okay so then i text him and this was
like a show i wasn't like working
full-time on
so i text the next day i go when am i
coming back in the room like it's just
like you're not taking like i i have
grace for you you're attracted to me
you're in a weird position where you
only hang out with people you work with
or whatever i'm giving you all the grace
in the world that i can possibly give
you that second time in you're not gonna
[ __ ] with me like that like you're not
gonna take away my like opportunities
and they never have like it never has
happened to me like that so
that's been good but it's like
it just is like where you're like what
the hell how impressive is that though
that you stood up for yourself
you then still like you said the next
day you still pursue the opportunity you
weren't like knocked down like i have to
move home i'm scared you [ __ ]
persevered and like now you have the
career
that you're supposed to have you're
authentically you
and there's no like male trying to [ __ ]
except for carlos but
i think that's so cool like the fact
that you went through that is awesome no
but i also feel like but i'm also angry
but also speaks to the fact that you're
well trained like like me you've had
countless of those experiences to where
it's like by the time you get to where
we're at now like you can see it a mile
away it's such a dance you have to do
because if you call it out the way that
you want to like
you're you are the cr they're like
you're crazy you're the like it's really
wild and this is not me being like
time's up i gotta take him down but it's
just like it's just the truth it's just
the truth of what happens and it's like
you just get sexualized whether you're
trying to or not or whatever you're
doing it's like i'm on stage going i
literally had a joke that was like i
don't like sex like i i would literally
go like i can't believe that i'm like
have you had sex sober it's disgusting
like i mean it was the whole set was
about how i hated having sex
and he's like sex sex
yes all girls talk about is sex it's
about like the same when the [ __ ] oh you
talked to me about his sex oh you've
talked to me about ever has been saying
it's the same way your body responds you
don't eat don't eat don't eat and then
all you do is eat yes right it's like
it's that they're just wired hard-wired
you know what i keep thinking about is
when dr drew told us that in the 70s
like there was this like air of teaching
men like women want the sex pulled out
of them like
make them do it like what they need men
to pull out our sexuality yeah they're
just waiting
what
like and that's probably men who
had that and also as the i would say
maybe the most avid comment reader of
the podcast it doesn't know i'm like oh
wow they're talking about it's like
we're trying to just like that when i
was just talking about the choking thing
like i'm telling that as like an
experience from like
my life that's like relatable i'm not
like doing this so you guys get boned if
you get boned up like that's
that's your but also responsibility
i'm not here like hey are you like yeah
you know like i'm talking to
i love my boy slugs but i'm talking to
the girls listen we're talking to the
girls we're happier here we love you
yeah but we are talking to the girl
we're very happy you're here we think
you're learning i think boy slugs are
going to change the world but
but honestly like
we're talking to the girls
let us talk to the girls the way we want
to talk to the girls this is not us
being like girls like [ __ ] go choke
on dicks even if you don't want to like
we're literally just like being
ourselves
also um if you think that
we're coming on the show and we're
always talking about sex i can assure
you when the cameras are off we talk
about sex even more
like that's literally all we talk about
it's something that
has been you know a source of
horrible ptsd but also a big source of
laughs and good times and bonding and
it's something that i just can't shut up
about even in my real life i like
talking about sex did i have one once
upon a time have dreams of becoming like
a sex scientist i did like i really did
i am fascinated that actually sounds
like what your job should be a sex
scientist
the observer well don't you feel
like also because we started stand up
around the same time there was this like
i'm so curious if you feel this because
for me i it was ingrained in me do not
talk about sex do not talk about
anything girly do not dress feminine do
not show your body and for the first
five years
even though all they're doing is trying
to [ __ ] you the entire time you're there
don't [ __ ] them but they're literally
that that's all they want is to [ __ ] you
so it's like i that's why i almost feel
like now i'm like oh i want to dress a
little sexy i want to talk freely about
sex because it was so like oh and also
how my interests were trivialized like
so what if i care about makeup and
clothes and all that stuff like it was
just i could never dare speak of those
things on stage because then the men
wouldn't relate to me yeah but don't you
think it's like i always think about it
like is this like a nature situation
where it's like me like women we're
naturally born with more empathy because
we have to take care of kids and stuff
like yeah like that we are able to like
sit through a man's like [ __ ] act
about his things that have nothing to do
with us because that's just like
okay like you're our sons your father
our brothers like our threshold
for
having to sit and listen through men
speaking
is really high sometimes i like i have
just glazed overlook and i'm like why am
i still here and i thought to myself i
am the [ __ ] mvp
women are the [ __ ] mvps do you think
we [ __ ] talk a lot and you have to
sit through the [ __ ] that we have to sit
through i'm like uh-huh uh-huh like i
need to get the [ __ ] i got [ __ ] do i go
masturbate at home
but why do i do that why do i just sit
there and i'm like but then if you're
like hey i don't want like i can't tell
you like i know i've talked about my one
ex boyfriend that i always see and he
like won't go like i'm always like okay
good and he just keeps it's like
can i just
i just want to set a boundary without
having to [ __ ] scream at you like can
i just go like hey i'm good like it's
all in love i just don't want to hear
about what project you're working on my
new goal for this podcast is i want to
have that guy on who wrote that article
um
that women aren't funny i think who it
carls who is it i want to have him on
here and i want to [ __ ] talk to him
and be like
let's let's do this well i want to know
if he's funny
oh this [ __ ] died at 62 in 2011.
oh damn it nevermind
esther you like graves
i love an opportunity for an example you
know what's funny but not not not that
funny esophageal cancer he was talking
too much [ __ ]
about women his esophagus i actually do
think that's real like i do think your
body
yes
your body
will take on whatever hatred is swarming
your body is going to become a hate
cancer he died at the hospital my dad
was trained at whoa your dad is our hero
your dad killed him
thanks mr probably dr herrera wait i
have a question for you guys what's your
what are your thoughts on ios allowing
you to unsend messages
oh i love it oh the guy at louis vuitton
said that
it's not good because
we're it's not reality unsend whatever
you want i don't care so you're saying
carlos that this guy thought it was not
good because it's not reality and we
should just allow for um to
for mistakes or
you shouldn't be able to correct a
mistake exactly because it's not real it
makes the texting less like a real
conversation it isn't real
i but what's the reason why what are
reasons did you guys oh wait oh my god
did you guys respond to me and then
unsend it yeah that's what it was
so what are you double ignored it's like
crazy like does this my phone work
she gets a new phone
let's let's um list the reasons why
people would understand okay i would
love to start because we do it on i do
it they have this feature on instagram
dms and i've already used it so like
sometimes this is so lame but like
i'll they'll be like a brand that i'm
like maybe they'll send me something for
free and i'll i'll go to message them
and then i'll see that i messaged them
two years ago and they never responded
so i'm like unsend that one and then
redo basically
i you know what i like about it it's
people can still see that you send
something like i know like on instagram
like people know like you know a lot of
times i don't like i look at something
and you don't know that i've looked at
it but i've looked at it absolutely if
that disappears like you're a fool to me
and like i feel like
one of the more embarrassing things than
sending something that you wish you
hadn't sent is getting caught deleting
it i that's yes i don't do it so
facebook messenger and whatsapp when you
unsend a message it tells you that the
person has unsent a message and to me
that makes me it i don't know it's never
a good feeling where i'm like and
sometimes i ask the person hey what what
what did you understand oh like it was
just a an error in like how i framed the
i'm like well why did you feel the need
to understand it like give me the typo
give me all of that you almost make
yourself more guilty like if you
accidentally send something
why why do you have to unsend it why
can't you just say oops i sent that back
exactly
i just don't send them i don't care it's
like
something happened on my phone once
where
one of my ex-boyfriends that i had a
really toxic relationship with
he had texted me such crazy he used to
get mad at me when i would like
i would go like to yoga or something
he'd still be asleep he would be like i
would have done the laundry and he'd be
like why the [ __ ] would some stupid
[ __ ] watch all wash all my shorts like
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you watch like he
would just be in like a weird he was
crazy he would be like screaming at me
on these texts like these long text
rings sounds like what i say to my mom
she washed it my dirty thing but it
would be like also like because then
he'd be like oh found them my bad ignore
that text or whatever
and there were so many of them like i
wish your boyfriend stabbed you in the
head like he was just like they were
like abusive crazy things he was a
writer he was very talented his insults
were very creative if i could
pull myself apart i was like this is
pretty good um
great listener but um
i i went back to look at the text like
after we had broken up
and somehow my phone deleted them i
don't know how that happened
it deleted them and
i was happy i don't want to have that in
my phone anymore i don't want to see
that it's okay
he's damaged it's not like i don't even
take it personally anymore it's like
good luck
uh
i really can't help goodbye i can't
think of a an example where i would use
that feature text can you
yeah
what
um
probably just to people that i like
love because sometimes if i um
feel extra emotional it's basically
sometimes i read a text that i send and
i felt very strongly about it in that
moment but i now look at it i'm like
well that was rude and inappropriate and
like annie said i don't want them to
have to open their messenger and see
that that's still there even though
we've made it you had like an impulsive
like
yeah let's say like you know let's say
it's my mom because i lash out at my mom
a lot because there's a lot of issues
she lost
so basically it's like there's i love
you mom good night darling i love you i
love you but above those text messages
is a very angry
thing that i had just sent her two days
ago
and it's like when she opens to text me
that's still there yeah and i don't want
we've already worked through that so
it's like i don't want to have that
there anymore
does that make sense it's just going to
remind her of of a a i thought you were
going to say a cute idea i thought you
were going to say something else i
thought you were going to say like you
were feeling over emotional and then you
got kind of embarrassed at how like nice
you were being because i used to when i
would do like in high school i was
really i'm very lucky but i would just
like find pills and snort them like i
just was like what yeah i just was like
i don't know i was a little druggie i
was just trying things out and that
backfired for me once but i took
something that made me so
emotional and like sappy that i wrote my
parents like poems
and i put them in envelopes i like
sealed them with a kiss i was like 15
you know
and this was when i was like really like
you know at odds with my parents and i
slid them
like under the door and i remember the
morning being like
oh i gotta get that back
we will see you guys next week for a
brand new episode and we're manifesting
you to subscribe okay
show us if it works or not
bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
you